عندما أتيت إلى سريالية في بعض الأحيان في
الليل بعد إغلاق المعرض ،
فإنها تشعر بالفراغ ما لم يكن هناك أشخاص
هنا ،
فالأمر يتعلق باحتضان الجمهور
واستمتاع الناس بلمس الماء المثير للإعجاب
بالموسيقى ،
بدأنا هذا المشروع عندما
أشركتنا سعادة ريم الهاشمي
لتطوير ساحة
يمكن للناس أن يستريحوا فيها ، فأنت تعلم أن المعرض
مليء بالأجنحة المثيرة ذات
التكنولوجيا العالية والثقافات الشيقة من
جميع أنحاء العالم
وشعرت أنه سيكون من الرائع
أن يكون لديك مكان يمكن للناس فيه
الاسترخاء وربما سماع الأصوات  من الطبيعة
بالماء ،
ما يثيرني حول هذه الميزة هو
أنها تفعل كل شيء تقريبًا على
عكس ما تتوقعه في
نافورة المياه التقليدية ، حيث ينطلق الماء
في الهواء هنا نبدأ
بالماء في الهواء ونسمح  الجاذبية
لإسقاطها ولكن بعد ذلك لدينا قطعة
من السحر نمارسها في المساء
حيث عندما ينزل الماء
تتباطأ ثم تأتي  نفرش
الجدران
ثم أخذنا الشيء الذي هو
عكس الماء وهو النار
ولدينا في الوسط كرات كبيرة من
النار الملونة التي اندلعت ولكنك تعلم أننا
لا نضيف القليل من الكربون إلى
الغلاف الجوي مع  تلك النيران
التي لا تحتوي على وقود كربوني والتي
تحترق فيها الهيدروجين النقي
[موسيقى
] أقول لكل من كان هنا
خلال النهار إنه رائع مع ضوء الشمس الذي
يتلألأ بالأمواج
ولكن عليك العودة ليلاً
لأنه عرض مختلف تمامًا
نمزج  لون مع هذه الموجات
تأتي مثل اللون الأحمر الفلوريسنت
والبرتقالي والأزرق ،
هناك عدد من الأشياء التي نتحمس لها
للغاية في هذه الميزة
إذا نظرت إلى الأسفل سترى أن
الماء أعني أنه قوي للغاية  موجات
ولكن يمكن الوصول إليها ويمكن للناس
الصعود ونسمح لهم بالتسلق
جزئيًا أعلى الجدار والأطفال الصغار
والأطفال الكبار أكبر
مني وهذا مختلف ، عادة ما يكون هناك
درابزين قديم كبير إلى اليمين.  إخراج الناس
من ينابيع المياه وأردنا
أن يتواصل الناس مع روح
الماء